hello everyone a lot of you have
requested I do a video on the Hungarian
attacking legend Rudolf Charles ik so
here it is the game was played in 1893
and in those days Shahrukh was
considered to be one of the top 10
players in the world only three years
from this game in 1896 he he defeated he
defeated the world champion Emmanuel
Lasker international tournament in
Nuremberg
so quite a guy and it was a Reuben fine
who said that watching rules games was
like reading good poetry now he started
learning chess when he was about 16
years old and he couldn't afford a chess
book or anything to start learning from
so he borrowed a really big chess book
and he copied it entirely by hand so for
those of you who have access to to chess
books and don't study from them I always
remember a rout of Charles II who had to
copy an entire book by hand at even have
anything to learn from so let's see this
game and I think it features an opening
I haven't shown yet on my channel it's
the Danish gambit so I do hope you enjoy
it
chapter SEC has the white pieces and he
opens the game with E for we had e5 and
yes his opponent is Jakob vulner the
reason why there is a hoodie guy there
for those of you who are older
subscribers to my channel do know the
story of the hoodie guy for those of you
who are new to this channel whenever I
can find any information or a photo of
someone's opponent then I use a photo of
a hoodie guy here and the reason I'm
wearing the hoodie is to honor the
hoodie guy so mister vulner here plays a
five and we have d4 he captures on d4 so
the central game is accepted and now c3
this is the Danish gambit we have D
captures on c3 Bishop to c4 and now
Knight to f6 here
why did like the client is B to pawn
unlike for some other gambits here if
anyone plays this against you with the
white pieces
feel free to capture the B to pawn as
well this is this is all fine for black
if you capture on B - yes he does play
Bishop captures on b2 and now he has
this
two strong bishops but you can easily
prevent this simply play b5 and after he
captures now comes Knight to f6 and this
will basically force the following
variation your opponent will capture on
f7 this is with check you capture the
bishop and after he captures your queen
now you play Bishop to b4 check unless
he wants to lose a piece he has to block
with the Queen otherwise they're gonna
grab the Queen with the rook
so after Queen blocks you capture it and
after Knight captures simply go rook to
e8 and white doesn't really have
anything here like it's perfectly fine
and the material is equal you'll you
won't have any problems playing this
game is black so if someone plays this
against you would white feel free to
capture the b2 pawn after Bishop to c4
but in those days mr. Wallner
didn't know this so he played Knight to
f6 which is still okay so this doesn't
give white anything really Knight to f3
again offering the B to pawn again mr.
Walden isn't interested we have Bishop
to c5 and now Knight captures on c3 d6
we have castles and castles and here it
seems the black managed to finish his
development the bishop is nicely placed
on c5 there's an item f6 and all of his
pieces are ready to enter the game
Bishop g4 maybe Knight coming to c6 so
it seems like black is even better here
he's not that much behind on development
one piece and he's up a pawn but those
were the good old days and white
immediately goes for Knight to g5 and
here a modern player if he saw this
Knight to g5 move he would simply ignore
it he would continue the game Knight to
c6 and he would keep his pawn advantage
but in those days people were people
were seeing ghosts pretty often so he
plays hh6 I wanting to kick away the
knight defending against a threat that
that really wasn't there and this gives
a route of an opportunity to create a
very nice attack he plays Knight
captures on f7
rook captures and now of course not
capturing with the bishop because to do
pieces are of course more valuable than
a rook but now he pushes a 5 and now you
can't capture the pawn if DK
actress Daniel was the queen the queen
is undefended nb8 and well your knight
is attacked on f6 so if you don't want
to be down a piece you have to move the
knight nice to h7 would have been a
better move but here mr. Wallner plays
Knight to g4 and here we have E six and
this is the critical moment in the game
it's also an interesting exercise I
guess for you guys to really feel what
what it feels like when you're attacked
so try to consider playing this position
with black and try to find the best
defense for black in this position even
pause the video for it as you know if
you if you put a lot of chest you will
play against a lot of aggressive players
and you will get attacked quite a lot so
being able to find a decent defensive
move is is just as valuable as being
able to find a decent attacking move so
I don't hope you were able to find it if
you have you're a great player and if
you just want to enjoy the show
the best defense here would be actually
rook captures on f2 because now if white
pushes a 7
this comes with check from the bishop on
c4 also the queen is now attacked now
comes Luke to f7 this blocks the check
from the bishop and also checks the
White King as the bishop and c5 is open
to an attack on the king and after King
to h1 not comes Queen captures on e7 and
after rook captures now you have this
Bishop to e6 move and this is the move
you have to find 36 and now if white
captures the Queen and now comes Knight
f2 check King do you want Knight
captures Queen on d1 again would a
discover check from the bishop King
moves Knight checks again King moves
Knight checks on d3 and after King moves
once again and now comes the bishop
captures on c4 and as you can see black
black is much better here so this is a
the move mr. Wallner
unfortunately missed so after a six he
tried Queen to h4 he decided okay my
opponent sacrificed a piece I'm gonna
sacrifice this rook on f7 and then I'm
gonna checkmate my opponent as I do have
a nice attack on h2 also three of my
pieces are attacking his F to pawn after
he captures rook
so no problems here
white played characters on f7 this would
check King to f8 and now Bishop to f4
Bishop 12 4 is an important defensive
move for white as the f2 pawn is
protected by the rook but now Bishop
protects the h2 pawn not allowing
checkmate
so here black played Knight captures on
f2 threatening all sorts of discoveries
also attacking the Queen Queen to e2 was
played and here Knight to g4 check we
have King to H King to h1 defending and
now comes Bishop to d7 not allowing
white to play Queen Queen to d8
checkmate so white improved rook a to e1
again threatening Queen to d8 and here
black really doesn't have a good
response here black tried Knight to c6
and now again you have a very nice
position to solve it's actually mate in
three for white so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find a nice
checkmate for white it's in three moves
I will give it a couple of seconds for
you to decide what do we want to pause
the video so those of you who were able
to solve it congratulations and if you
solved the first one as well then you're
an amazing player and for those of you
just want to enjoy the show
the move is relatively simple its Queen
to d8 check here like doesn't really
have any options he has to capture it it
doesn't matter if black captures with
the bishop or Tobruk the idea is the
same we had rook captures which check
and now comes pawn captures rook and now
it doesn't matter what what buy plays
there's only one move you can only
capture the Queen with the bishop and
after Bishop captures and out comes
Bishop captures on d6 it's a discovered
check from the rook also it's check from
the bishop the bishop is slicing all the
way here so this is checkmate so I do
hope you were able to find this and I do
hope you enjoyed this game by the
Hungarian attacking legend rudolf
chatter sec and if you face the Danish
gambit often in your own games maybe now
you will be able to defend properly by
knowing that you can really capture the
beat coupon and still play a good game
with black so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
that maybe I will show his win against
Lasker as it's also as it's also a very
impressive game I would like to thank
Jeff gaspin and Christopher Gleason for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon
probably tomorrow morning with an
announcement video for my celebratory
stream thank you and I will see you soon